so david thank you very much for being
with us this morning and good morning to
you uh so just first of all your
reaction to what we're seeing for these
next couple of days i mean we always
fear that we reach these temperatures
but have we reached them sooner than
scientists expected
uh
if if you ask me that question about
what scientists expected 10 years ago
the answer is yes but we we have now
seen a new weather pattern emerging
which is impacting the whole of the
northern hemisphere
and it will also impact the southern
hemisphere and what i've talked about
here is the fact that the arctic circle
region has been over the last 10 years
heating up about four times faster than
the rest of the planet which means that
the average temperature above the
level that existed before we started
burning fossil fuels
it is about 3.5 degrees centigrade above
that level
and for the rest of the planet we're on
1.35
and rapidly approaching 1.5 so
this is something we hadn't quite
anticipated the loss of ice over the
arctic ocean
has proceeded much more quickly than any
climate scientist predicted and today 50
percent of the arctic ocean is exposed
to sunlight and that polar summer brings
the sun right right through the day
and so what what we have is the arctic
circle region becoming one of the warmer
regions of the northern hemisphere
during the three polar summer months
and that is driving the temperatures
around the world in a very strange way
it's led by
this wind that blows
in an anti-clockwise direction around
the north pole
this this wind
is a strong wind
and it's been blowing in a virtual
circle around the north pole for a long
time
it is now severely distorted and the
result of that distortion is all of the
extreme weather events we're seeing now
the heat wave we're seeing is coming up
from
the equatorial region in africa through
north africa through spain and portugal
portugal experiencing temperatures of 47
degrees centigrade
that's a record in portugal for for july
and
and now this year hitting britain as
well i think it's critically important
to understand that in previous heat
waves over the last three years we have
managed to escape them although the
highest
previous temperature recorded in england
was of course in cambridge in 2019 where
the temperature of 38.9 degrees
centigrade was was recorded
so all of this
is now predictable
and we have to revise our opinions these
heat waves will repeat themselves and
get more severe going forward in time
we're not going to have to wait to the
end of the century for that
to happen it's already happening on a
regular basis around the northern
hemisphere david it's bad and it's going
to get worse so that leaves the question
what can we do about it at this stage
so
as emergencies all of the advice that's
being given must be taken
everyone has to understand even a fit
healthy person is at risk our normal
body temperature is 37 degrees
any temperature above 37 even in the
shade
is therefore putting us at risk you're
needing to get rid of that excess heat
the way we do that this is through
perspiration
but if we perspire
by dripping we're not perspiring by
evaporating water into the air as water
vapor
and we lose all the cooling advantage in
that process the heat required to turn
water into vapor is what is taken from
your body in that normal perspiration
process but if we start dripping sweat
then it becomes very dangerous so i
think two things one stay in a cool
place of course
two
look for a windy place as well so that
you're getting the wind to blow the
perspiration off your body and cool you
and and thirdly if you can get hold of a
fan use a fan to keep yourself cool
go into the coolest part of the building
you're in if you happen to be in a flat
on the top floor of a building with a
flat roof above you that flat is likely
to be very hot
you need to perhaps go down into the
basement of the building which will be
the coolest place many many things need
to be done sorry to interrupt you sir
david but we don't have endless amounts
of time and i didn't want to get on to a
thought about the way that governments
are sort of dealing with this i mean you
will have seen that some of the
conservative party candidates for
leadership want to scrap the net zero
targets by 2050 i mean
balances have to be struck don't they
tough decisions have to be made but how
concerned are you that the decisions
we're making to try and save the
environment here perhaps aren't enough
and may actually get pushed back and we
won't actually meet some of the targets
we've set ourselves
i've been involved in this within
government from 2000
until 2017 so i've worked for all four
prime ministers over those that period
of time
and frankly there's a lot of nonsense
being talked about this costing our gdp
growth if we if we hit net zeros sooner
rather than later
we have found that switching across to
renewable energy sources such as
offshore wind the most successful of all
for britain offshore wind
has been a tremendous financial success
it's a wealth maker not a wealth taker
but and at the same time we're dealing
with the major problems but at the same
time
the government needs to grasp the nettle
of the importance of public services
national health service needs further
funding it's no good just exhorting
people to work harder when there's a
crisis it needs further funding we need
our health services properly funded as
the sixth wealthiest nation in the world
here we are with an ambulance service
barely operating like it should be
operating
and at the same time we need also to
understand that we have a crisis
with us now and it means that we have to
prepare to adapt to living in a hotter
climate but we also have to take
measures to see if we can somehow
re-freeze the arctic which is the group
that i've set up in in cambridge the
climate
[Music]
the center for climate repair at
cambridge is working on how we might
even re-freeze the arctic if we can do
that then stop these extreme weather
events we're buying time to allow us to
reduce emissions deeply and rapidly and
also to remove excess greenhouse gases
at scale from the atmosphere all of the
above needs the attention of government
in britain we're saying we're going to
switch over to electric vehicles
how are we going to do that if we don't
see it as a public service that there
are charging points
along streets where there's no off
street parking for the people living in
those streets we need a real focus from
government on public investment for this
public good
okay so david king do you really
appreciate your your time and expertise
this morning re-freezing the arctic is a
fascinating idea uh we don't have time
to explore it today but i'm sure we will
perhaps in our climate show at one point
uh sir david king former special
representative for climate change do
appreciate time thank you for being with
us